[Music]  Adam gotta go he is an ordinary kid  but when he discovers the secret of his  missing father it will take him on the  adventure of a lifetime  who are you I'm not sure how to break  this to you but I'm your dad my dad is  Bigfoot yep could my life get any worse  no am I gonna be like you  you'd have symptoms by now like hair  that grows a foot overnight pull eat  that blow through the ends of my shoes  there's one more thing you can talk to  animals how you doing pleased to meet  you I left because I was being hunted  they'll stop at nothing to get what they  want dad needs help the only way we  stand a chance is if we work together  already I was born ready it's doing  professional show you how it's done  [Music]  the son of Bigfoot  [Music]